ciao a tutti bentornati su alice stories
oggi andiamo ad aprire ea vedere i nuovi
drive e scrissi che sono arrivati da
tiger ne ho preso un bel po e sono
superficie di vedere come sono quindi mi
raccomando lasciato in bella è che se
volete vedere altri video in cui a volos
line provos qui si è sempre eccetera a
10.000 lycett ne farò altri e se vuoi
entrare a far parte della stessa vi
basta iscrivervi attivare le notifiche
lasciare bella ex questo video e
seguirmi senza grande il nome è
all'interista e ora siete pronti
iniziamo subito allora non sono quale
iniziare
penso che magari iniziamo da questi
perché è da un bel po che egli voglio
provare le prossime bel po in pratica
sono arrivato questi nomi zen da tiger
che sono degli slime make quindi per una
sorta di storia non fai da te c'è una
polverina da intrusioni bicchierini sono
super curioso di vedere come sono cielo
sia azzurro che cosa fate sapere nei
commenti preferite l'azzurro ho
preferito europa il suo indecisa perché
sono i mille colori preferiti
praticamente allora con quale inizia
qua
[Applauso]
[Musica]
iniziamo con questo il rota ok
leggiamo subito le istruzioni dopo
abbiamo ad aprire gli altri tre tra
l'altro un paio di squilli che ho preso
di che sono fantastici non sempre più
squisito si chiamano quelli con la roba
denti squisito non mi ricordo mai il
nome
ok allora andiamo ad aprire questo
contenitore e li troviamo questa ci sono
degli adesivi con scritto fatto da in
inglese nei by quindi che volendo potete
attaccarli qua e un po dietro le
istituzioni allora perché dobbiamo fare
è innanzitutto dobbiamo mettere tutta la
polverina deve con delle formazioni non
le forbici palme di uno scontro fini se
metto giusta fondersi di queste cose si
chiede da bagnare renato noi in serata
casinò effettuiamo tutta la sua onde poi
quindi appare allora poi bisogna mettere
60 ml di acqua saranno per me
come vediamo cosa succede ora bisogna
chiudere e agitarlo attenzione però per
30 secondi che è fatto ora bisogna
aspettare dieci minuti ora faccio anche
quello di celeste poi li lasciamo qua
per 10 minuti evidente qua dentro
e nel frattempo andiamo a vedere gli
altri che andiamo a fare velocemente
questo ci aspettiamo come il colore
della portella e quelli lasciamo
riposare per un pochino trasferimento
qua così vediamo che succede qualcosa
adesso magari si scopre il gusto è
bellissimo colore ha creato c'è stata
sempre lei stick sono due e poi vorreste
che per il colore della polverina
ufficiale è chiaro in questo modo a
mettere un pochino più indicato per
queste cose qua ho fatto abbiamo messo
un pochino di più
ora vado ad accettarlo per 30 secondi
finché un consiglio fanno in genere
dovete quando dovete contare contate in
un'altra lingua penso che ancora vi
altro fatto i numeri in inglese perché
vi aiuto un sacco a memorizzarli quindi
un'ipoteca deve contare vuol dire lo fa
foto nostra lingua non in italiano
perché sicuramente quelli di tagliare
nel quale dimenticherete perché non
siete come me che avete una confusione
di lingua e testa però contate sempre in
inglese oppure se state parla un'altra
lingua francese spagnolo quante altre
info contatti con la lingua perché mi
aiuta a ricordare il primo incontro fra
tutte made by me
ok ne vado che queste si stanno formando
vi faccio vedere tutto mi potrebbe
essere spesi per ho detto una cosa
proprio spessissimo tipo quelli squisito
in salumi come si chiamano comunque
questo è più un giocattolo diciamo però
lo prezzo perché mi fa troppo ridere è
troppo simpatico ma ve lo posso vedere
in pratica azioni squalo e non fosse
vedete bene ma se un piede umano
se poi io schiacciate in piedi e realtà
è stato vitale come la cosa da ricavare
da in un sacco di questo corto tiro che
qua tipo un cappello rosa vedete c'è più
la gamba dentro
e non lo sto mito attribuire è quello di
far vedere quindi lo stretto
guardate come si muove il piede ma
credetemi di commesse anche secondo
questi infatti forse etico inquietante
perché del mit uns magari intorno locri
rock taglierò formatter o in un live
come faccio ogni tanto per i miei stessi
fatemi sapere se volete che li maggiore
momento non lo zaino poi altro species
quesito e questo è tutto
non l'ho visto c'era sia rotta che viola
dovesse foto è bellissimo
allora guardate questa è una conchiglia
ok normale conchiglia che ciò come
apertura fa cosa si stava dentro ci sono
tutte altro bellissimo ed è super
antistress e perché sono queste perle
che siamo qui insieme a tra l'altro che
non pensando adesso mi piacerebbe
scagliarlo e cliccare le parole dei 36
un po mi dispiace volevo provare a tutti
troppo vediamo se si toglie esperti non
romperlo wow è tolto un bellissimo che
così lo stesso durante stress e con
queste questo fondi li ha dentro
e sì anche questo sto pensando di
scagliarlo e credo che giusto fatemi
sapere titolo taglieremo secolo staimo
state preferite che lo conservo perché è
bellissimo riuscirà ora di mettere
dentro allora adesso non c'entra ma nel
video è di colore controllano la mia
volta si chiamava the mist andato a
vederlo dopo questo video mi ha chiesto
come che nome dare a questo unico drink
per carino e grazie per tutte le idee
che mi avete scritto avete scritto un
sacco di nomi bellissimi ma che hanno
iscritto che neanche nome fitto ha detto
quindi seppure sua vita delle con voi
che non c'è scritto pareggio e poi
deciderò se preferisco i no che ci fa
quando perché mi avete succede che voi
vediamo c'è scritto pegasus è il mio
compleanno e il 12
mi piace nome bega quindi scegliere un
nome che quindi se volete dare un nome
unico nino andate a vedere nei video i
miei follower controllano la mia vita
per 24 ore e scrivete il nome che volete
usare a questo bellissimo uniformi poche
e raspino slime e questo ha fatto una
sorta di tema di conchiglie ora da biker
comunque è questo forma di conchiglia è
scritto che dentro ci sono delle perle e
bisogna trovarle quindi sono super
curiosi riaprirlo tra l'altro il colore
mettesse un fatto che portal in azzurro
chiaro perde acqua quindi apriamo
permettiamo se ricevuto farle sempre
andiamo ad aprirlo nella bottiglia tra
quelli come che così sto valido
prendiamo in persone mani e molto molto
gelatinoso cross cercando di capire che
sei come i storiche su anita iker moto
gelatinosi ho sentito una perna i
volturi fine sempre di quelli gelati
noti però il colore penso che sia che il
più bello
mai fatto il veto del verme che ce ne
sono solo due
vediamo tutte le altre e anche qua
niente ma come italia perché mettere con
solo due perle sotterrata mettere
qualche bella su quel carine come queste
cose fly ma è il solito perché marmi 3
dentro superlibri i gruppi non lamentela
tinoso di tiger però il colore è molto
bello
vediamo
[Musica]
ok porterò la tratta di sapere nei
commenti se piace diamo un po tutte le
cose non rompe di fatto allora di molto
tutte le cose che voto date da una dieci
a uno squaletto che si mangia manca un
pò umana che voto date da 1 a 10
qui si corre padre dentro che voto date
doma 10 onlus line con le perle dentro
scrivete nei commenti
e ora di morte il profumo france privat
live hanno fatto dalle prime nel
secchiello line nel contenitore un po
più grande infatti mostrargli un po più
grande di colori quelli che ho visto io
c'ero questo arancione è quello perde ma
sinceramente mi sono stufato len barrie
perché alberghi pensa per il driver
decreti belli ma non lo so ma non mi
piacciono tanto il cancro sveglia che
stava 4 euro questo però insomma per la
quantità di città e mi piace questa
concezione perché anche se non dovete
piacermi la flai una questa confezione
si può riutilizzare per un po solamente
carcere a quest'altro squish che
presumono nicolò stiamo davo un fatto
vedere l'anno preso da tiger reti fu una
navicella spaziale e 40 quando un
apprendimento
scusate l'interruzione dallo slang ma
non sono perry cordate che non l'avevo
fatto vedere guardate tutti i
brillantini dentro bellissimo abbiamo
finalmente la alcuni con la porta
attenti quando perché posso klein di
tipo arancione blu o meno male devo dire
non fa moltissimi suoni ed è lo stesso
un gelatino pacchetti a queste grande in
mezzo al cinema non sempre più
rilassante rispetto a quelli piccoli
viviamo tirino fuori vediamo come si
deve dire che quello g questo e si
chiama l'assistenza è sempre lo stesso
da il tiger diete che si spezza su e
quella sempre gelatinosa però mi piace
il fatto che sia così grande che siano
in un porco con lo zio ciro della mia
faccia ti dico perché finora sa che non
avevano mai fatto un tema così grande e
appunto è bello il march la mano dentro
nel contenitore però si purtroppo è
sempre quello zero sinodo sempre la
stessa con sospetto facciamo in qualche
modo dentro pensa comunque quindi questo
era lo slime nel contenitore grande lo
stadio grande
fatemi sapere pica lamiere fatemi sapere
che voto gli date da 1 a 10 e questo è
ora è arrivato il momento di vedere come
sono diventato
come mostrano tassi non so cosa ho fatto
cosa ho fatto di sbagliato ma e
appiccicoso e con un uso non so se sia
anche un nesso tra poco cava qua
peccato non so davvero cosa sia successo
con coprono aspettare un pochino
macchiato un po
ora vediamo come t28 colleghi siamo o
meglio vediamo anche qua nel coperchio è
rimasto di rimasuglio anche questo mi
sembra un po pizzico però a meno bloom
imita no perché la pizzi cosa che quel
ok ho aspettato altri dieci minuti
vediamo ora come sono e non ci sto
pensando
potrei aggiungere un po di soluzione tra
clienti e vedere informazione influisce
un po mi sembra che sia in i ragazzi si
è indurito quindi dovevo semplicemente
lasciarne di più e senza troppo quindi
andiamo a vedere come allora
innanzitutto non capisco perché ci sono
così tanti che mi a me sembra di averlo
mischiato bene quando bisognava scuotere
il contenitore quindi magari che lo
prendete dovete assicurarvi discutere
bel contenitore comunque la consistenza
e un po dalla sinistra come gli altri
però è molto più allungabile rispetto
agli altri plan di tiger vedete
vediamo se fa qualche sogno
[Musica]
a qualche sono in più effettivamente
rispetto
quindi se di coesistenza un pochino
meglio anche se non è grandissimo quelle
andiamo ora a vedere quel che anche
questo anche se rimane un pochino
appiccicoso ancora un pochino che ci
cosa questo forse ha un po meno con un
mi è rimasto appiccicato premi come
tripodi istruzioni per lenti vediamo
cosa succede ha funzionato ragazzi che
non è più così cosa che meno
vediamo se questa bestioni che questi
fanno un pochino più dispone rispetto a
quelli di certo che la consistenza una
piazza di più rispetto a previsioni
sinusiti e un piccolino se non sbaglio
in passato a 2 euro
quando voi e rimettete nella scatolina e
quando sneijder caminetto fatemi sapere
se volete che riunisca o se volete che
unisca tutti gli studenti tiger magari
scrivetelo nei commenti e vediamo se
questo migliore tutti i diecimila life
sorte mi traverse volete vedere altri
video recensioni e anche qual è la cosa
non è piaciuta di più di tutte queste
cose che ho preso da tiger scrivetelo
pure nei commenti
e ora mi lasciava al 34 cappelline in
cui potete andare a vedere i prossimi
video ad esempio shopping da tiger video
con altri slime cliccate su quella che
preferite e buona migliore